what does our government know about the
UFO mystery one long time intelligence
official has seen more of the Pentagon
files than anyone he is the
Terry man to work on three major UFO
investigations including one based here
in Las Vegas the official is Jay
Stratton and he has never spoken in
public or even granted an interview that
is until he sat down with our very own
George Knapp of our 8 news now
investigators
when a mysterious object dubbed the Tic
Tac UFO befuddled U.S Navy aviators and
sensors off the coast of San Diego in
2004 the incident was dropped not
investigated the first in-depth probe
happened five years later under the
auspices of a then secretive program
called OSAP the advanced Aerospace
Weapons Systems application program
created by the defense intelligence
agency with black budget funding
spearheaded by Nevada Senator Harry Reid
Tic Tac was the first UFO incident
tackled by OSAP and its contractor Las
Vegas Aerospace Pioneer Robert Bigelow
the report was released by us in 2018
Jay Stratton is the man who wrote it
every time I've done anything related to
UAP or UFO has been my job
um and and what I mean by that I didn't
really have a passion growing up I
didn't have all the books so I didn't
watch all the TV shows I stepped into a
job I at the defense intelligence agency
where some things came across the desk
from 2008 until 2021 pretty much
everything UFO related came across Jay
stratton's desk he made the decision to
ditch the term UFO and use UAP instead
unidentified aerial phenomena Stratton
worked at the highest levels of Naval
intelligence then was loaned to the DIA
where he excelled at reverse engineering
he and his colleague rocket scientist Dr
James lacaski kept seeing reports of
unknown craft but learned there was no
central location where such Mysteries
were being analyzed you know all the
stories you hear right there's probably
in the the office that deals with this
and as we tried to find that office we
found nothing so they created one
stratton's colleague Dr laketsky had
been reading about a UFO hotspot
nicknamed Skinwalker Ranch after a visit
to the Utah property lacaski pitched the
creation of a formal investigation Harry
Reid agreed to fund it Robert Bigelow
landed the contract Stratton consulted
with the allsap program and then with
its successor atip when the head of atip
Lou Elizondo resigned and revealed its
existence to the New York Times in 2017
Stratton was asked by his boss if he
jumped back in and cobbled together a
new program he did and that effort was
eventually formalized by congress with a
new name the UAP Task Force One of
stratton's projects was the creation of
a comprehensive but classified briefing
that included UAP videos and photos
collected by the military most of those
images are still unreleased but a few
objects encountered off the east coast
and even stranger objects buzzing Navy
ships on the west coast were leaked then
publicized Stratton scopes at the
debunkers who tried to explain them away
as players or drones or
there's a lot of cleanup to do when when
you when you have a lot of these people
saying it's birds or whatever they're
saying
um it's frustrating because you know the
rest of the story and you can't tell the
rest of the story in 2021 Stratton left
the task force but his work formed the
basis of a stunning report to Congress
stratton's Chief scientist was Dr Travis
Taylor now well known for his television
appearances of 144 incidents
investigated by the task force 143 were
considered unidentified Stratton and
Taylor now work for radiance
Technologies a defense contractor with
offices in 17 States including Nevada
when Stratton and Taylor showed up in
the audience of An Alabama UAP
conference last summer UFO circles were
abuzz with questions about what their
employer might be up to filmmaker Jeremy
Corbell brought his cameras to record
our interviews Stratton admitted there
are still more questions than answers
probably remember the infamous quote
from Congress that let's hope it's
aliens George Knapp 8 News Now